so i'm going to talk about community
building in the 21st century
and share a little bit about some of the
early uh
adventures in community building that we
began
doing with general assembly a few years
ago when we first started
so a little bit about me first of all
graduated from yale in 2009
moved to new york city uh while i was at
yale i did a couple of entrepreneurial
endeavors
um freshman year i started an antique
furniture business
um which we discovered that yale was
renovating all these old buildings and
so we started buying up
old pieces of antique furniture for like
nothing from yale
and um created an e-commerce site an
online brand uh ebay store and sold them
for like
you know a thousand percent markup um so
that was sort of my first hustle
uh and then after that um started a more
traditional tech startup
um called go cross campus which i
started junior year
at yale we're basically taking um sports
rivalries and college rivalries and
putting them online and
building these sort of massively
multiplayer social communities and games
online allowing people to live out their
their school rivalries unfortunately we
never really figured out how to generate
any revenue with that one which
apparently is important for running a
business
you know so they say um and we end up
raising a couple million venture capital
uh the recession hit in early 2008. um
we tried to raise another round and
it wasn't happening our bank account was
just going in one direction
um we also made a lot of first-time
founder mistakes and you know we had to
shut that company down and
it failed and i said i graduated 2009
and so this startup failed right when i
was graduating and my whole plan was all
right i'm gonna go graduate
from school and work full-time as
co-founder of my own
startup unfortunately that's only
possible if said startup actually exists
and has money which it didn't so moved
to new york
um you know i never really had a i've
never had a real job
so to speak um but
you know as i moved to new york and i'll
talk about this in a minute um
about a year in after moving to new york
um with a couple
couple other friends started general
assembly
and you know now fast forward a little
bit to today 2015 you know we've raised
just about 50 million dollars in funding
we just hit over 500 employees
um our hr team told us the other day and
um we have campuses in 14 cities around
the world so
quite a lot of growth in the last few
years and they can talk about you know
some of the early community strategies
that we
pursued to to get to where we are today
i also
you know about a year or so ago started
a very large side project
um still full-time in general assembly
but uh daybreaker is another thing i
started which
has now expanded pretty pretty rapidly
we're at nine cities globally
um and counting and that's that's for a
separate talk um but we're in san
francisco if you guys
are up for an early morning dance party
um all right so
let's um let's talk about sort of the
problem the situation here
um so rewind to 2009 right
the recession had hit new york city um
this is where is where i was based you
know and i'm seeing that
the recession that hit and tech was
really transforming every single
industry out there
whether it was um retail or journalism
or advertising or finance
or fashion you know technology was
transformed in these industries and
companies were changing the kinds of
talent that employers were hiring for
was changing
at the same time you know we were seeing
that the new york tech scene was really
starting to blow up it was starting to
become this burgeoning
real thing and i know you know here in
the bay area you guys have been doing
this for decades
um in 2009 you know it had been like a
few years you know it was very exciting
at the time um
but it was it was pretty ad-hoc and
somewhat disjointed you know there's a
meet-up here
an event there and um it didn't feel
like it was as cohesive as we thought
you know maybe it could be at the same
time
due to the recession you had a lot of
people who were seeking new career paths
they were coming out of traditional
industries maybe they had lost their job
or corporate jobs were less secure and
less available
as people once thought employers were
looking for new kinds of skills
people were realizing you know what you
know tech is becoming more and more of a
thing maybe i need some tech skills
maybe i need to make myself more
marketable
you also had a lot of young people
coming out of college and with just
their college degree
they weren't marketable you know it
wasn't it was hard for for young people
to find jobs with just a college degree
people looking for new inspiration new
communities new opportunities so that
was
that was a situation um we were seeing
all this
and you know we sort of had this idea
what if we could create
a physical place not an incubator not an
investment firm not a vc um
and not just a co-working space either
but let's create a physical place a
community nucleus if you will
for the startup ecosystem in new york
city a place where people come could
come together
to learn from each other to collaborate
professionally
and to interact socially right so we
really believe that
you know there shouldn't be these walls
between your educational life
your professional life and your social
life but in today's world and especially
where we think you know things are going
and and
most um obviously what we were saying
the startup space
it was better with all those things or
all those walls those separations
are torn down and that your your
personal
um world and your professional pursuits
and your intellectual
educational life were maybe a little bit
more seamless so we set out to
create a physical home a hub where all
this you know activity could happen and
we could
create that kind of um create some sort
of nuclear fusion
um that could spark you know new
companies new ideas new opportunities
um for people in new york city so i want
to talk about then how we did it
right what we what we did um
a couple of tactics so i'm gonna talk
about six tactics activate the core
these are community building tactics
that we really pursued early on um
and and this is sort of the the meat of
um of i think what we did that really
worked
activate the core give karma get karma
establish clear norms and values
create meaningful offline experiences
balance curation with openness and be
authentic and live your mission
so let's dive in activate the core this
image
is the ace hotel you guys might have
been there um in the flat iron district
um before general assembly i was hanging
out here a lot this is sort of my
my daytime home base it was a place
where people would go and work on their
startups code have meetings have coffees
get mentorships hang out listen to music
whatever
and it sort of was one of the
inspirational places for ga early on
so when you think about activate the
core and what was you know some of the
the
piece of advice there or you know one
really focus your early efforts on
building a powerful
um sort of central core of true
believers so
you know what we did with general
assembly was um a lot of a lot of
one-on-one coffees a lot of
conversations you know i would bring
people that i met
to the ace hotel you know when i moved
to new york i knew maybe 10 people
i just graduated from college you know i
didn't really have a network but i
started to go to events
i started go to meetups i started to
meet people i started to get
introductions
and i started to tell people about this
thing called general assembly that i was
working on
and a lot of that early relationship
building was really useful and really
necessary
i would organize group dinners where i'd
bring together different people who i'd
met
who were interested and excited about
this idea of general assembly
wanted to share when to give ideas give
advice they wanted to be a part of it
they wanted to you know help
and i was really encouraging of those
people to give that
to us and and see you know how can we
help you how can you help us
let's think about this as a as a
community gathering and so
small group dinners um were useful space
tours we would
we before we actually took a lease on
our first campus
i brought in maybe 100 different
individuals vcs engineers entrepreneurs
designers etc
brought them into the space in the raw
empty space
and said what would you have here what
would you want to see in this campus
what do you think about this classroom
setup what do you think about this open
desk plan what do you think about having
a lounge
and a big communal table here getting
people's invite advice and insights
getting their feedback
that way they became more invested in
what we're doing as opposed to us just
trying to sell them
you know i was really asking them what
would you want here what would be useful
for you
um i was also you know manually building
our email list so our first 1000 people
on our email list
were individuals that i had either met
and talked to about general assembly
at an event or a coffee or what have you
also people who
might email back and forth so i would
keep a tab open in my browser
every time that i emailed with someone
or i met someone an event any
interaction that i had with an
individual about general assembly i
would take their email address throw it
into a tab
put it into our mailchimp list and then
a few months later once we started to
really
get the word out and start to spread
spread the news about this thing
i had a thousand people who were already
familiar with general assembly
and that was really you know how we were
able to build that that core audience
we also um we didn't actually raise
money until about nine months
into launching general assembly and how
we were able to do that was we were able
to
get a grant uh from the city of new york
to help get started
we sold some corporate sponsorships i
got some corporate sponsors to uh to
give us some cash
and then we pre-sold co-working
memberships before we launched
so activating this really core community
of true believers we got startups before
we even opened to say
yes i want to be a part of this thing i
want to join general assembly and i'm
willing to give you some money to hold
my spot and to guarantee membership in
this space
and that's how we funded the build out
of the campus and and the signing of the
lease
and so immediately when we opened up we
were totally full and we're already
generating revenue
and so you know those early adopters
that you cultivate will become your
evangelists if you do well by them
they'll do well by you which brings me
in my second
um my second tactic give karma get karma
so you know one of the things i really
encourage in community building
is try to be as useful as possible give
connect inspire people support them do
whatever you can
to help them in their mission you know
when i as i said early on when we were
first getting started
um you know we been launched right we
thought well we don't have anything to
give you we're not offering classes
we're not offering
space you know we're not teaching
workshops yet however
we started making introductions and
probably every day for the first year
i would make maybe five to ten
introductions a day
and those well-placed intros add value
to the ecosystem
everyone benefits and by then i mean if
you if you find two people
who don't know each other right but
probably should
um you know i came across a lot of
people in our early networking community
building days
you know let's say someone's working on
a fashion startup and then there's an
investor
over here you know i met a few days
later interested in fashion startup
opportunities
if they didn't know each other i would
get in touch and say hey do you guys
know each other because you should
probably connect
and i would make that introduction and
both of them would benefit from having
known each other
and i would look good for doing it right
and i wouldn't lose anything
you know it wasn't a zero-sum game you
would just add value to the ecosystem
so the more that you just send out karma
and add value to the ecosystem making
introductions
offering advice being as useful as you
possibly can you never know exactly how
that's going to come back to you you
know serendipitously
and i was never really asking for
anything in return i never you know
said well i'm making all these
introductions for you how about you know
you give something back to me
i just try to be as useful as i possibly
could to anyone in my network
and then you know a year or so later
when we're launching general assembly we
needed
instructors or we were looking for
sponsors or corporate partners or
investors
and we sort of put those asks out into
the universe people just
sent back support in throws because they
knew that we were such an
additive positive part of the community
so there's that there's that karma piece
that's very very real even if it's uh
hard to you know
point to tangibly number three establish
clear norms and values
so i think this is really really
important when you're first starting and
building your community
really codify the founding principles of
your brand
think about what those are even maybe
even before you launch what what are the
what are the core
community values and principles that you
want to drive the brand everything else
should flow out of that
start with those values start with your
those principles figure out what matters
to you and what how what values you want
the community to believe in as well
and so how we did that is we actually
encouraged a culture of reciprocity
um through a physical we call it search
engine and it was these two huge
bulletin boards
and on the bulletin board we had a piece
of paper and you could say
um i'm offering bl i'm a blank and i'm
offering
you know blank and you say i'm a
developer and i'm offering free
um mentoring for people interested in
learning how to code
or you know i need um
a ux designer to help me with my mobile
app and people could post this stuff
physically
and you know we weren't asking we're
taking a cut of any deals that happen
we just encouraged people to put what
you're offering and what you need
and then encourage people to connect in
real life to share and give back to each
other
so that culture of reciprocity was a was
one of our our core community values
and we really encouraged that physically
in the in the community space
a couple of the other values that we we
chose to really inspire and drive our
community
um these are the six that we chose the
general assembly obviously you know when
you guys are building your communities
and growing your audiences
choose your own um people before the
machine you know that's
that's sort of a key one you know it's
realized generally something's about the
people
it's about the individuals it's not so
much about um
you know the technology is is much as
much about transforming people's lives
passion and purpose really encouraging
people to think about
where they want to go what matters to
them not just not just making a lot of
money in their careers
own your own path that was another
important one this idea of
choosing um you know taking an
entrepreneurial approach to your career
essentially even if you don't
necessarily want to be an entrepreneur
right now and start your own company
in this day and age um you know people
are changing
changing jobs uh every couple of years
and so it's important to know what
skills
you're looking for it's important to
know where you're going where you want
to take your career path
because there's not some sort of great
pathway that says here's how to be
successful follow these paths
ultimately it comes down to you and you
figuring out what does success mean to
me what's going to make me happy how am
i going to find meaning
number four create meaningful offline
experiences
this is an event we did general assembly
did with pencils of promise which is a
really cool
non-profit organization building schools
all over the developing world and you
know
we we really tried to do a lot of um
a lot of offline sort of magical
engaging experiences that would create
really
memorable moments for people that they
would take with them through their weeks
and
and through their days you know there's
so much talk about online ux design
right and user experience
and a lot of that is referring to a
mobile app or a web app or something
right
one of the things we thought a lot about
is well what about offline ux design
what about experience design right how
can we create experiences
that are magical and memorable how can
we get people engaging in real life
you know people connect far more deeply
offline than they do online you know
there's only so much interaction you can
have with another human through a
message board or through a group or
through a
message you know text or something like
that or through an image but getting
people together in real life
and set the lighting and the music and
the
the entertainment and the vibe and the
people and the speakers that create the
content create these
you know really magical experiences that
people are going to take with them
and remember and say wow that was
powerful i met some great people i
connected with others
and i have now a much stronger
connection to the brand or the product
or the organizer
putting putting this experience on a
couple of examples there
um you know we uh we did we did an event
called heartbeats
um uh a number of times actually here in
san francisco new york hong kong london
a few of our cities and essentials a
social event where we set one design
constraint
we said okay there's a social event
where there's one rule and the rule is
you cannot talk about your job
so no one could go around and say what
do you do you know because that's such a
common networking thing right that's the
first question everyone asks
is that well if you can't talk about
what you do for a living and instead we
encourage people to talk about what you
love to do outside of what you do for a
living
you know music art activities um hobbies
whatever it is and it got people
interacting in a really interesting way
and it was a lot more memorable and
interesting of an experience than you
know just your typical networking event
um a couple of other ideas you know
fireside chats
um live bands you know try to try to
break the norm try to create original
memorable experiences um that people are
gonna take away because that's
the drives community in a big way number
five balance curation with openness this
is this is tricky
you know with any community that you
want to build there's really this
balance right so a really tightly
curated membership
um where you're very selective about who
you want in and
choosing you know just the most
incredible people will yield quality
individuals and a great community and
high quality interaction
at the same time to the outside might
come across as unwelcoming
too exclusive to clubby and this was a
concern that we had with general
assembly we said okay well
you know early on we offered whoever
co-working and it was this
invite-only membership-based co-working
um
community and we really wanted to make
sure that it wasn't just pay to play
that it wasn't just anyone off the
street
but that you could actually um but
the only like really high quality
startups and entrepreneurs were able to
be a part of that community
right and once by doing that we knew
that people in that community the
members
would know all right there's some
minimum bar of quality i can let
my guard down a little bit i can feel
familiar with these people
i can interact with them knowing that
the other people here are
sort of like-minded and of my same ilk
right
however we knew that if we just did that
you know we had to run the risk of
becoming you know
an exclusive club or a membership that
would feel weird to the people who are
outside right
and so we said okay let's have a curated
invite only
community of co-working members but then
take all of our programming all of our
classes and events and workshops
and open that up to the public and have
that be an opportunity for anyone who
was interested in learning skills
getting involved in the startup scene
you know making it right that they could
come in and feel like that they were a
part of the ga community as well
so think about how you want to do that
balance curation you know for quality
but also make sure that you're welcoming
and open um because that's important for
putting your brand as well
and then last um be authentic and live
your mission
so you know be earnest think about think
about what
how can you authentically live the
values of
of your community and of your your brand
um if you're building a community you
really need to care about your people
right so
the spirit remember i talk about those
core values and core norms
you need to live those yourself every
day you know if you're not living those
values if you're not living those
principles on a day-to-day basis
basis your community is going to know it
and they're going to feel it it's going
to feel inauthentic
if you're trying to get other people to
um to participate in these things you're
not doing it yourself then you're being
a
a bad leader you know i think um as a
community builder you're you're a
convener
you're a facilitator you're you're
you're a public servant right
you were there for your people you're
not a celebrity
it should not be about you it should be
about them um i remember early on you
know people said that the early
you know early couple of years of
general assembly community building felt
like this grassroots political campaign
um and i remember you know i knew that
we were doing something right
when about three months before we
launched our campus so
this is maybe november of 2010 we
launched in january of 2011.
in november of 2010 we didn't have a
website we didn't get any press we
avoided
all publicity and press until actually
we opened
and i had again brought about 100 people
through the space i had tons of coffees
dinners
a lot of that grassroots community
building and
i started here people were telling me
hey brymer
um i was at this meetup last night and
you know and i wasn't there i wasn't at
that meetup i was at this meetup last
night
and one of the big topics of
conversation between all the attendees
was
general assembly and people were excited
about it people didn't know what it was
but they were excited it was it was
awesome and they heard rumors and they
were they were getting pumped
and i knew that something was going
right if other people
were talking about general assembly and
spreading that message and getting
doing that community building and it
wasn't just me
you know hustling and preaching but that
i'd gotten other people excited enough
because they
saw that i was authentically believing
in this stuff and that they sort of
took those reins themselves
and so you know what what had happened
is really you know became
a nucleus of the startup ecosystem in
new york this is me a couple years ago
um giving a talk uh one of our most
popular talks um introducing the new
york startup community at the french
embassy in new york actually
um which was pretty pretty wild um but
we you know within six months of launch
you know people were telling us people
were coming to us saying
ga is like a core center nucleus of the
new york startup community which was
kind of our dream from the very
beginning and it was just so amazing to
hear other people tell us that
you know we had 10 times the number of
applicants then could physically
fit into the co-working space and almost
every single night we were running
classes and workshops and talks that
were sold out you know we knew that we
were doing something right
we knew that there was a product market
fit there we knew that the community was
vibrant enough
that people were coming to us and and
willing to spend some money to be a part
of that community to learn
to collaborate to meet other people and
you know as we grew our community and
brand became you know pretty well known
and respected in the industry
and um you know about about maybe six or
seven months in
in launching in you know sort of
mid-2011
we said okay we sort of made it as like
a core hub of the startup community in
new york
great um but we thought you know what we
think we actually have a little bit of a
bigger vision on our hands
um and this it's not just about being
the center of the startup ecosystem in
new york that's that's great that's fine
um but we realized you know what we have
all these people coming to us
seeking community seeking inspiration
but also
seeking to be relevant and seeking
skills and opportunities in
the the rapidly changing 21st century
economy
and so we thought you know what we may
have something bigger and the bigger
vision was to realize
we can actually build an entirely new
kind of educational institution
one that focuses not on pieces of paper
not on giving degrees
but focuses on giving people really
practical vocational skills and 21st
century topics like technology design
business marketing etc as well as
plugging them into a really supportive
community and network of fellow doers
and practitioners and creators
and also creating opportunities for our
graduates and alumni so that as they go
out into the world
we can actually get them jobs we can
actually help them start companies we
can actually
help them find work that they're
passionate about
and help you know them um
help empower them to pursue work that
they love that was that was the bigger
vision that we realized
and that's what we've been pursuing now
um ever since the last
last three or four years so this is a
map of a bunch of our campuses right now
we have physical
physical campuses and in these cities
all over the world um
with more coming soon you know we do a
lot more a lot of online education now
as well but really the heart and soul of
what we do
is in person very hands-on educational
experiences that are
transforming people's lives for the
better
so what's next what's next for us
um as i said you know we're really
focused on transforming people's lives
and empowering them to pursue their
calling so we want to make sure that
anyone who's willing to work hard and
follow their passions
can have a meaningful career pursuing
work that they love
and we intend to build a long-term
educational institution that will be
around for decades
you know we're not here to you know flip
something we're not here to build
something that's going to be short-lived
you know we're teaching you know ruby on
rails and
lean ux and um and you know google
analytics
right and just as a handful of little
topics right that we offer
that's what we're teaching now in 2015
right well in 2020 2025
we don't know what we're going to be
teaching we know it's going to be
relevant to those years and we know it's
going to be practical and useful
and transformative and community
oriented but it means that we constantly
need to be updating our curriculum and
evolving
to meet the needs of you know the
present and the near future
so that when our students come to us
whether they've taken a class before
they haven't
we make sure that they're getting what
they need to make them relevant as
successful as possible
in the day and age that it is and so
when we think about building an
educational institution to last we're
never finished right we're always
evolving it's always changing
things are never totally stable you know
we intend to grow
our community to become really probably
the most valuable and indispensable part
of what we're doing
we want to make sure that the general
assembly community is as personally and
as professionally valuable as possible
for our alumni
so the skills training and the the
workshops and the courses and the
educational programs
getting people jobs all that's really
critical right but ultimately in the
long term we want to make sure that if
someone's
looking for a job looking to level up in
their career looking for new skills
looking for
opportunities looking for a co-founder
whatever that the first place they come
to
is their general assembly alumni
community and that you know we want that
to be one of the most
valuable assets that we have at general
assembly and so that's why community
building is so important
and i think for a lot of a lot of
companies a lot of businesses i think
you know that
your community of customers of clients
or users or whatever
the more that you cultivate that and the
more that you make that as strong as
possible
not just with your interactions to them
you know not just the brand
interactions with uh with the
individuals but how can you get the
individuals interacting with each other
you know we can only do so much for our
alumni but the more that we can help
connect our alumni up to each other
and create means and values and and
a culture of reciprocity so that our
alumni are helping each other
that's how we can scale this community
to become you know
a truly global um and powerful powerful
network
so you know we're about this by this
year i think we'll be about 25 000
alumni
in our in our in our community and
that's that's growing fast and
you know we intend to continue to expand
around the globe with online and offline
so want to thank you all for um having
me up here i'll take a couple of
questions
here's my contact info social profiles
but yeah thanks for having me take a
couple questions
thank you matt if anyone has any
questions come on down awesome
well first i want to thank you for
coming and speaking to us i think you
brought up a lot of really good points
and i definitely learned a lot from you
so
i guess one of my first questions is
more focused on
scaling the community and still
maintaining that personal touch so
how have you been doing that how do you
plan to continue to do that
totally um right so as i said we're
about by the end of this we have about
25 000 alumni right there's a lot of
people
um we first started our campus new york
city we had two or three hundred
people right and it's a lot easier to
create a really tight-knit cult
you know cultural um energy and
community with just a couple hundred
people it's much harder to do with those
larger amounts
so i think what i would i would say and
how we're thinking about it is it all
comes down to nested
communities right 25 000 is a large
number of people
um and it's hard to feel much intimacy
there so what we do
is you know we have as i said you saw
that map right we have physical campuses
in all these different cities
right so within that larger 25 000
network um
every city is building community right
so new york has their community right
and that might be a couple thousand
people right
and then within that you know any one
city um
there's individual courses right so any
one course might be
25 people right in our in a general
assembly and so
it starts by having that nested core
community of 25 people
in a class getting those people
interacting and tightly engaged
very loyal to each other right and then
you have that
sort of um that's like the smallest
circle
right and then let's say that's a ux
course right we might have events or
programs that bring together all of our
students in new york who've taken
that particular ux course so that might
be several hundred people
right we'll get those people interacting
and start to build community at that
size
right and then we'll have alumni um
events or we'll have like a quarterly
commencement
where we'll invite all of our alumni
from the last year or so
back to participate in a quarterly
commencement ceremony
and that brings people from the whole
new york uh network together so
it really comes down to i think these
tight sort of small nested communities
and then
and building out from there awesome
thanks all right
cool thanks everyone